what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome to hype train this is the new
show that we have here on pop culture
explain right this show is designed to
run over like rumors and all that kind
of stuff right never to get you guys all
hyped and everything for stuff that's
coming later on down the line now
here's the thing falcon in the winter
soldier is going to give us young
avengers how do i know
okay check this out right this is this
is crazy this is this is a crazy thing
all right so the first question we have
to ask here is who are the young
avengers right so the young avengers
consisted of about six people right you
had billy kaplan you had cassie lang you
had teddy altman also known as hulkling
you had iron lad
kate bishop and you had eli bradley who
went by the name patriot so the whole
idea behind the young avengers is they
were technically an
unsanctioned superhero team what this
meant was that in the aftermath of
everything that had gone on with regards
to like civil war and avengers
disassembled and all that kind of stuff
that a young group of kids basically
picked up the mantle right especially
after avengers disassembled those of you
guys who don't know avengers
disassembled was a story that led into
house of m
so basically scarlet witch went nuts but
one of the things that she did is she
had manipulated tony stark to make him
look drunk
in front of the united nations i think
it was and the result was that the stock
value of stark industries just plummeted
and because tony stark was the one who
bankrolled the avengers he couldn't
afford to do it anymore so he basically
had to stop funding the team the team
couldn't really operate as a team
anymore because they didn't have any
money so they basically disbanded you
think they would have opened like a
gofundme account or something like that
but like they didn't
they didn't have any money so the result
of that is the young avengers basically
stepped up as like these young kids who
were like well if we don't have avengers
proper then we'll just go forward and
we'll fight villains and various people
and things like that and just call
ourselves the young avengers it wasn't
until
the aftermath of house of m and a story
called the children's crusade
that the young avengers were actually
recognized by the avengers as an actual
team
okay so how do i think that we're going
to end up getting this team all right so
we know the avengers in the traditional
sense don't really exist anymore in the
marvel cinematic universe they kind of
do but they kind of don't right tony
stark's dead captain america steve
rogers is aged up
falcon like sam wilson doesn't want to
be captain america we saw that from
falcon in the winter soldier neither
does bucky barnes right so there really
is no captain
america at the moment i mean i guess
there is if you take into account john
walker u.s patriot but like he's a poor
man's captain america and he's obviously
not going to keep the role forever i've
got my own theory about him because i
think his story arc is going to be
amazing black widow is basically dead
right she's died she's at the equation
now gone like we're not gonna see her
anymore unless for some reason they
decide to bring her back you do have
hawkeye but he's seemingly more or less
retired nick fury's running
sword so like there really isn't an
avengers team anymore so they're gonna
need
another avengers team now here's a cool
thing to keep in mind the sokovia
accords
are still in effect it's very easy to
forget about those or to believe that
they were somehow mixed
in the aftermath of like the events of
in-game and like everybody vanishing and
all that kind of stuff no
the sokovia accords from civil war which
basically govern how superheroes can and
cannot function
those are still law those still exist
out there and so when the sokovia cores
were introduced they were more or less
imposed on the original avengers team
which led to the events of civil war and
so wouldn't it be interesting if we got
something that was akin to like the
initiative for marvel comics thrown into
the marvel cinematic universe
here's the initiative right a lot of you
guys probably don't know what that is in
marvel comics in the original civil war
event that whole story more or less
followed
in terms of ideology what you saw in the
marvel cinematic universe right tony
stark believed that superheroes needed
to be registered and needed to be
monitored by the government otherwise
the government would just crack down on
them entirely and you would more or less
get days of future past captain america
didn't believe so captain america were
like no no no freedom you know yada yada
all that kind of stuff and so what ended
up happening is the bad guys
quote unquote won reed richards hank pym
ant-man tony stark the guys who were
in favor of registration they
essentially came out on top right
captain america surrendered himself at
the end of the civil war comic and that
was basically it then he died a little
while later in the death of captain
america's storyline and so what you got
in the aftermath of that was something
called the 50 state initiative and this
was essentially an event whereby new
superheroes would be trained to
basically have
avengers in all 50 states but they were
government sanctioned and they were
trained at different locations you had
the quote unquote main avengers training
facility but then they were like kind of
sent out into other states and they sort
of trained based on like the laws of
those states and different things along
those lines if you're going to create
the young avengers the best way to do
this would be to basically say okay so
like we're going to have young people
that we notice have powers we realize
how capable they are we can't have a
scarlet witch situation where someone's
got these insane levels of power and
then just sort of runs awry and that's
basically it so we are going to
basically take these young people with
these extraordinary abilities if they
choose to do so and we're going to train
them to become superheroes they're going
to become the young avengers and then
once they finish their training they go
forward into the united states serving
in whatever capacity we want them to
serve but i'm not saying it's gonna be
an exact 50-state initiative thing but
like that's basically what you're gonna
get
now the cool thing is that we already
see a lot of these guys here right a lot
of the characters that'll be part of the
new avengers already exists in the
marvel cinematic universe right you
start with billy kaplan and with tommy
kaplan or we're really gonna just kind
of go with like billy and tommy maximoff
we saw them quote unquote disintegrate
or disappear when wanda undid everything
at the end of one division but then we
heard their voices in the post-credits
scene
[Music]
i think wanda subconsciously brought
them back but if you have kids who
are the children of what is arguably the
most powerful being to have ever existed
on earth the quote-unquote scarlet witch
then it makes perfect sense that they
would be inducted into the young
avengers trained on how to use their
powers and then go forward accordingly
you've got cassie lang cassie lang's the
daughter of scotland we know that she's
a teenager now because we saw her in
avengers in game when scotland returned
home and then his daughter answered the
door and then they hugged and it was
that nice little moment and all that
kind of stuff but she's the perfect age
to be part of the young avengers now
you've got well we don't really have
kate
kate bishop we know she exists and we
know that like we're gonna get her
character that's been confirmed by the
marvel cinematic universe those of you
guys who don't know
kate bishop was the second version of
hawkeye you had clint barton and then
you had kate bishop a lot of people
speculated it was gonna be clint's
daughter that's probably not gonna
happen but we're gonna actually get
kate bishop in terms of iron lad he's
nathaniel richards basically a version
of reed richard's dad who kind of exists
across
the whole universe and different time
periods it's really weird and confusing
doesn't matter we have not seen him yet
teddy altman also known as hulkling we
have not seen him but there's no reason
to believe that we won't teddy altman
his father was a cree and his mother was
a scroll now we know from the captain
marvel film
that like decree and the scroll are not
friends right they're not besties but as
with any major conflict like there's
gonna be situations where you have a
member of one race and a member of
another
while their race is at war with each
other the two of them fall in love right
it's like the old romeo and juliet story
kind of thing right you know two warring
families and
somehow you know a member of each family
falls in love and it's a forbidden love
you know all that kind of stuff whatever
the form is it'd be very easy for us to
get hulkling if we haven't gotten him
already right because we saw that like
the whole cree and the scroll concept
was brought in in captain marvel that
took place during the 90s is it really
outside the realm of possibility that
like a cree and a scroll found each
other fell in love knocked some boots
and popped out a kid i don't really
think it is right and if that's the case
if it happened around that time then
that means hulking would be around 20 25
years old at this moment so he's
a little too old to be a young avenger
but if you kind of back that up and say
that hey like the korean scrolls right
they they met at a bar somewhere and and
you know they were listening to shakira
one thing led to and
led to another they had a few drinks and
before you knew it it was a one-night
stand
it happens sometimes you know you got
preggers and you know now we got hulking
that's entirely possible right not
outside the realm of possibility eli
bradley patriot is one of the coolest
things right that ties
directly into steve rogers those of you
guys who don't know about this the idea
is that in the in marvel comics
following steve rogers being frozen in
ice and presumed to have been dead the
federal government tried over and over
and over again to make new super
soldiers what you got was an instance
whereby they snatched up 300
african-american soldiers in mississippi
and then subjected them to a series of
serum enhancements and training
processes designed to create a new
captain america it was pretty gruesome
only a handful of them survived one of
which was eli bradley's grandfather the
result was that these enhancements he
passed down through each generation and
so the father of eli bradley enlisted in
vietnam eli bradley himself has all
these super soldier enhancements as well
that's how he becomes patriot right he's
just like teenage version of captain
america more or less you guys see how
all how the stage is set for
all this stuff it's not outside the
realm of possibility so i think that
what you're gonna end up getting here at
the end of falcon in the winter soldier
even if it's only in a post-credits
scene or something kind of built up over
the course of the show
is you're gonna have this sort of
situation where where sam wilson
officially steps into the role as
captain america right that's that's his
story arc for this for this whole season
i guarantee it right the first episode
sets the fact that like he doesn't want
that role it's basically carol danvers
from captain marvel from the kelly sue
deconic run if you guys never read that
all that really happened is you had a
guy by the name of captain marvel
right now after he died you had monica
rambo who played spectrum who eventually
took on the the mantle of captain marvel
and then she got rid of it when she
became like photon and then spectrum and
so what you ended up having was carol
danvers who
essentially met with steve rogers
captain america and he's like you should
be the new captain marvel and she's like
no i don't want to take that role right
that belongs to marvel and then
essentially she ends up taking it anyway
right she kind of steps into this iconic
role
that fate i guess was meant for her and
then she officially becomes captain
marvel right that whole run was by kelly
sue to connick it was amazing that's
basically what's going on with sam
wilson right sam wilson is just like i
don't want to be
captain america right that's an iconic
name and an iconic role and i'm not
ready for that you know and the whole
story arc for falcon of the winter
soldier is going to be at the end of the
series he's going to officially become
captain america right step into the role
but if that's the case like when that
happens all it's gonna be is
okay so like now that i'm captain
america we need a new avengers team
real credits right that's that's what
you're gonna get right so it's gonna be
like the young avengers essentially it's
entirely possible that we get this
you'll see new avengers come out of that
but we've already been told by the
marvel cinematic universe the falcon of
the winter soldier is gonna set up
three new titles right three new
projects i guarantee one of them is
gonna be the young avengers and this
show is gonna start setting it up with
that being said guys let me know what
you think down in the comment section
let me know what you guys think about
this idea for a show and i will catch
you all later
peace